welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
host of the show but today i do have a
very special very temporary guest
co-host his name is greg knuckles greg
thank you for joining me thanks for
having me on how's your day going so far
ah
it's going well how's yours
good i uh i i took a little hike this
morning to a creek did some meditation
uh
enjoying this weather it's gonna get
cold soon so i figured we had a nice
warm sunny day
uh definitely took advantage of it had a
great morning is it really gonna get
cold again it is it's gonna be in the
30s pretty soon here uh fahrenheit like
as a high no no no it's a low
but uh but yeah so
anyway we got a great show today uh
that's not all about our local weather
uh fortunately uh but before we get into
the show uh
if you enjoy the show and you want to
support it there are many ways to do it
you can like rate and subscribe wherever
you happen to access the show
you could go to
bulksupplements.com and use our discount
code sbs pod that'll get you a five
percent discount off of your entire
order you could subscribe to the mass
research review which greg and i are
co-authors of along with dr mike zordos
and dr eric helms or you could check out
macro factor that is our diet app it
does have a free trial and if you love
it and we think you will then you can
subscribe
all right uh road to the stage how's it
going greg
uh it's going well sorry i just need to
re-gather my thoughts i was just
checking the the 10-day weather forecast
yeah that's not good
god damn it uh yeah so um
road to the stage going well um
this past week actually i was on
vacation um my wife and i were down in
bradenton florida
not for any particular reason just to
take a little break uh and
the reason the the weather is
is germane to this conversation
is uh
the the biggest reason we went is yeah
you know it's getting towards the end of
the cold season and we just wanted some
warm weather um
and we were anticipating like yeah you
know middle of march that tends to be
when things start warming up in north
carolina we were basically hoping that
we could get uh an extra early week of
spring and then just basically carry
that that on through so
much to my dismay i see 50s in the
future uh
like thursday and sunday here but yeah
you you actually left during a bit of a
heat wave and then
now that you're home it's like back to
normal
oh well that's fine anyways so uh
yeah on vacation this past week and with
that in mind one of the things that i
wanted to do
on vacation was basically to
uh not be that concerned about the road
to the stage not intentionally try to be
in a calorie deficit not track anything
like just basically chill for the week
[Music]
and just listen to my hunger and satiety
cues with the
explicit goal of just trying to maintain
weight
and not put on like 10 pounds in a week
as i occasionally do on vacation and uh
yeah
that on that front it was a complete
unmitigated success uh came back about a
pound heavier than when i left and i
think that's purely down to the fact
that traveling makes me constipated so
probably uh tmi
that's good to know for us yeah uh so
for the listeners maybe tmi but anyway
uh
that that bit went very well
um and i i you know it's it's a small
thing but i'm actually quite proud of it
um
just because i do think that that
is a positive reflection of the skills
that i've built over this past year
and an improved ability to
listen to my
typically very faint uh regulatory cues
as far as satiety goes
so yeah
feel good about it no that's awesome
it's
very overlooked commonly in the dieting
space but
being able to kind of
reconnect with some of those cues and
let those take over um you know that's a
kind of a skill that we can uh
we can practice and develop but we can
also kind of
fall out of that that regulated zone you
know so that's a really a really
positive step there for sure
how was the road to athens yeah the road
to athens is good so a while back i
mentioned i had a popliteous injury
which is uh the most meaningless muscle
in the human body uh it is a complete
joke but when it hurts it's not fun man
it's not fun to run with that so
my pop lydias is feeling a lot better
and you know with the the weather the
last several days it's been a really
nice stretch of of long runs which is
something i've been missing so
uh because my pop lydias is way better
i'm back on the trails which means i'm
more likely to
get out there on a warm sunny day and
really just go for it
so
right now i've got a really nice uh
balance where
some of my runs are like three miles and
they're very brisk like i try to really
push the pace and build up my tolerance
for higher intensity efforts
and i mix in some of the longer trail
runs which tend to be like six to ten
miles and i'm getting to the point now
like i can give you a really nice eight
miles in well under an hour keep a
really steady clip the whole time and as
long as i don't get bored i'm good to go
so that that's why the trail running
comes into play it's so much more
enjoyable than just running on the
street
um now i was like back in the day i was
hoping to do a specific marathon that's
actually this month um once i ran into
those injuries i was like i don't know
if that's gonna work and then they
actually changed the venue of the
marathon from a perfect venue to an
absolutely terrible venue it's it's like
through the city and it is literally in
the mountains and stuff like the city is
like straight inclines and declines the
whole way so anyway i'm not doing that
marathon the injury messed up my
training uh trajectory and the venue
change is awful
um
but i'm still keeping an eye out i'll
probably do something either in the fall
or next spring
uh which is not unusual for me so like
even with like bodybuilding contest prep
i usually just start prepping
and then somewhere along the way i
identify a show usually pretty late in
the process so i'm taking the same
approach here where i'm definitely still
training
fully intend to do a formal marathon
like i'm not just going to go off on my
own and say yeah i ran 26 miles like i
do want to enter one and do it and kind
of make it official and enjoy that that
kind of culmination of the training with
a a specific event
um but yeah so i haven't picked one yet
but that'll be coming um but yeah things
are going well uh what about feats of
strength this week what do we got yeah
so i've got two um
if you follow strength sports at all you
are probably aware that the arnold
classic uh wrapped up recently uh
wrapped up yesterday at the time of
recording wrapped up i think four days
ago at the time that this episode will
be airing
but either way that that happened pretty
recently so i have one feet of strength
from the arnold classic and i have one
feet of strength from
the crazy world of multiply equipped
bench press
so
which one do you want to start with
let's start with the arnold
all right so uh
if so if you're listening to this and
you follow strongman or string sports at
all uh you may have heard of the demi
stones they are a legendary pair of just
two very big stones from scotland um
and
they
in in total weigh
732 pounds i believe uh or
what's that like 332
333 kilos give or take um
and so
lifting the denny stones is something
that
uh you know a lot of people have done it
now but it's um historically been viewed
as a great test of strength for people
who
respect like global odd lifting culture
like getting away from just barbells and
classical implements
so very very cool uh just big rocks that
you can pick up
so anyway um at the arnold this past
weekend
a light weight uh
a lightweight female strong woman named
chloe brennan lifted the dimmy stones
and uh she is
i'm sure the lightest woman ever to do
it she might be the the lightest person
ever to lift the denny stones one thing
to note about them is they're
notoriously hard to hold on to because
they have ring handles instead of just
kind of like flat
handles
so you can't get as good of a grip on it
like you know basically the the handle
is going to be sitting really deep
on your ring and middle finger and it's
it's hard to get your your pinky finger
into it as much which doesn't matter
quite as much and also your your pointer
finger which matters quite a bit more
um
and strength aside that just sounds
horribly uncomfortable oh yeah yeah so
it's also just going to cut into your
hands feel like [ __ ]
so they're hard to hold on to
and they're also hard to pick up and
balance because they're two different
sizes uh you know it's they're not well
calibrated in uh implements i think one
of them is a little over 400 pounds and
the other one is a little under 300
pounds
and so you also have to lift it with a
really awkward
stature so
the really really big strong men
sometimes compete on like denny's stone
carries where they pick it up as if
you're doing farmer's walks like one in
each hand kind of off balance but you
know just one on each side of your body
but for just a classic denny stone lift
you do it like uh oh what do you what do
you call it like a jefferson deadline
yeah a jefferson deadlift that's that's
exactly what i was trying to come up
with um
so yeah you're like you have one in
front of you one behind you
and so like your torso is rotated uh and
just like the stones are big so it's not
like you're grabbing right in front of
your torso and right behind your torso
like one's going to be in front of you a
decent little bit the other handle is
going to be behind you a decent little
bit so it's very awkward and very heavy
and very hard to hold on to so like
even though it it's like a partial
deadlift range of motion um like a lot
of people i i i've never tried to lift
the dinny stones i would love to but
like talking to people who have tried um
you know it's it's in no way analogous
to like a 700 pound uh block pull or
rack pull it it's just it's very heavy
and also very awkward so anyway um
chloe brennan
took him down
i i i think she might just be like the
third or fourth woman ever to do it and
like i said doing it at 140 pounds
absolutely ridiculous um and also if you
go and watch the video it's very cool
because she didn't get it on her first
attempt like she was trying to hook grip
it and she had tape on her thumbs for
hook grip
but in in addition to being rings on the
stones it's also not knurled the way a
barbell would be um and so i think like
the thumb tape for hook grip helps your
thumbs like bite into knurling a little
bit better so she tries it hook grip
with thumb tape uh
i think one of them breaks the ground
the other one doesn't so she takes the
thumb tape off chalks up tries again uh
still doesn't quite get it and like you
know if you've ever pulled a max
deadlift
you know that
if if you have an attempt where you give
it everything you got maybe the bar
breaks the ground a little bit but
doesn't go up if you try that pull again
30 seconds later you're not gonna get it
like that's that's not how max deadlifts
are accomplished uh but you know like
it's a competition i'm pretty sure she's
on the clock she's got to do it she just
says like [ __ ] it i'm taking one more
pull at it and uh
and she did it so
so was this at the arnold yeah
the the stones there's only two right so
like did they have to bring them in from
scotland
i i'm pretty sure
she did this on the actual denny stones
and not a replica yeah yeah so i'm
pretty sure they shipped them in wow
that's pretty cool yeah yeah the the
jefferson deadlift is is one of my
favorite lifts because it is
conditionally impressive and what i mean
by that is if you go to a commercial gym
and you do jefferson deadlifts and you
don't visibly look very strong
people will assume you are a complete
dumbass yeah but if you do look visually
quite strong
people will be like wow that is very
advanced like
it either makes you look stupid or very
cool just depending on
people's assumptions about your strength
level yeah yeah yeah um so yeah that was
one of the feats of strength very
impressive lift very cool video you
should go check it out uh the other one
um so okay here's here's a little pop
quiz for you eric okay
so powerlifting has been around for a
while i think we can all agree
if someone were to
i don't know
break a bench press record
how much how much do you think they
would break it by uh and we'll we'll
categorize this less than 50 pounds
between
uh 50 pounds and 100 pounds or by more
than 100 pounds just how by what
increments do you think these records
should be advancing by certainly less
than 50. yeah so you think that because
you're a [ __ ] idiot well no i think
that because russia breaks a world
record every three weeks and it's always
by
the next increment no yeah i mean that's
that's what everyone would think um but
on i think like two episodes two or
three episodes ago we talked about uh
the most recent um unlimited gear bench
press record set by
uh
you know long time
power lifter uh bill gillespie a real
classic in the sport sets the bench
press record rides off into the sunset
very cool story so that was 1129 pounds
and uh his record was recently broken by
jimmy cobb uh who was the previous bench
press world record holder before bill
gillespie took the record uh and he
benched 320 pounds or
uh
599 kilos i don't think he quite did the
600 i think it was it was on pound
plates um yeah 1320 so basically
improving the record by 200 pounds very
very close to it um
just uh
an outrageously impressive lift so a
couple of things about this is one um
i think he's going to take this record
much higher so
for for people who have never
either dabbled in or just like spectated
equipped lifting which that's not an
assumption i can make anymore back back
when i got into powerlifting like
multiply was the big sport in america
with raw being kind of uh
a lesser cousin that is very much
flipped there aren't that many people
doing
like unlimited gear powerlifting anymore
and certainly not as many people
spectating it so anyway just a little
bit about lifting gear
there are three broad categories there's
single ply
there's multiply and then there's
unlimited and the unlimited category was
made specifically for like the new types
of bent shirts so with a single ply
shirt basically like you're gonna have
like denim or canvas or just like some
sort of
very slightly elastic but stiff material
that
you know helps resist the bar as it's
going down and assists you going back up
with multiply instead of just one layer
of that material you can have as many as
you want and then with unlimited uh
there's a new style of bench press of
bench shirt on the market which is like
truly elastic
like rubberized equipment that
uh
assists as i understand it quite a bit
more than even like the old multiply
shirts did and so jimmy cobb had the
prior
um
like unlimited tier bench press world
record at 11 20 before bill gillespie
broke it with 11 29
and bill gillespie used one of the like
very cool new rubberized shirts jimmy
cobb's old record was single ply so he
he had previously benched more single
ply than anyone else had ever benched
multiply or with the new just crazy bent
shirts uh so i think this was his first
meet that he did with one of the crazy
rubberized bench shirts and took his
meat pr from 11 20 to 13 20 in a single
meet um and there there's footage of him
on his instagram account taking uh over
1400 pounds to a one board makes it look
easy
so
we might be about to see something
just insane out of him once he gets more
practice
with this type of equipment
also
you know we
aren't always the most congratulatory of
lifting technique when it comes to
i wouldn't even say technique just just
like standards when it comes to multiply
or unlimited lifting like oftentimes the
squats are of questionable depth maybe
the deadlifts don't look totally locked
out maybe the bench presses don't look
totally locked out or look like they
have a clean pawls or whatever um
but
i i wouldn't even say as far as equip
lifting goes just as far as lifting goes
this is a clean bench press um
lowers it under control very clear pause
very clear lockout
like i i think this is the most
just legit looking
uh bench press world record in terms of
like
adherence to the rule book which isn't
always adhered to uh i this is this is
one of the best looking bench press
world records in a long long time
um
and
god i had one more thing that i was
going to say about it
well in the meantime uh
i don't want to step on your toes here
but i do want to protect you from the
vitriol and hate mail
you mentioned 13 20 and 599 kilograms
but the link says 1302 and 590. is is
the is incorrect yeah the link is
incorrect oh wow yeah so that's
impressive because if it was only 1302 i
wouldn't really care but 1320 is is
something yes um yeah yeah so i remember
the other thing i wanted to add this is
the heaviest lift
in powerlifting history
yeah uh
the it's not supposed to be i i i mean
the biggest deadlift is clearly below
that yeah and the biggest squat
i think the biggest squad is either 1300
right on the nose or 1305
um
so yeah just just to illustrate how
large of an effect power lifting gear
can have
i i think this is the first time the
bench press record has been higher than
the squat record um
but you know that day has arrived and
uh you know like i
it should be clear i think geared
lifting is very cool i think that's a
minority position among among raw
lifters these days um i think it's
awesome it's
it is a completely different sport you
can't compare them apples to apples and
if someone like if someone asks you like
how much do you bench and you say 800
but it's like an equipped 800. like
i think that's a little dishonest
because they
are thinking you're talking about the
type of bench press they're thinking
about which is a raw bench press um so
yeah you can't compare the sports apples
to apples but i think it's very cool
just just because of how much weight
they're handling um
and like from training with equip
lifters like the the crew of guys i
trained with when i first got into
powerlifting like i was the only raw guy
in the crew everyone else
lifted equipped and just seeing
what it took to get under loads like
that crazy
um and there was a guy in our crew joey
smith who was
like an 800 plus venture at 275
and like that that was very very good at
the time
and i remember
you know i remember him loading like
over a thousand on the bar and doing
like a reverse band to board press with
like over a thousand pounds and you know
just seeing
you know even though it's a partial
range of motion the bands are helping a
little bit just seeing like
what that did to him to just hold that
much weight in his hands and then just
and like the heaviest the heaviest like
binge press i felt in my hands with like
um
uh like to a four board using like
really heavy bands as kind of like a
bench shirt or like a slingshot
which i'll note if you don't want to buy
a slingshot but you have access to bands
you can just double them over put them
around your arms it's literally the
exact same thing that's what we all did
before uh before those existed
um
but anyway so like doing like a high
board press with with the bands around
my arms like i felt 600 in my hands
before
and that's [ __ ] scary it's
like you can feel
one it just feels like the um
like the cartilage in your wrist is
being compressed and you can feel your
forearms flexing like your radius and
ulna
you can you can feel them like flowing
yeah yeah um
and i mean you know i'm sure 600 would
feel very different if i got into equip
lifting and was handling that type of
weight more frequently but i can't
i can't even conceive of what 1300
pounds would feel like in my hands yeah
that's that's outrageous to me so just
the fact that not only can he bench it
but just just that he can touch it like
he can unrack that without his forearm
shattering
outrageous to me um
so yeah new bench press record and who
[ __ ] knows might be 1500 in a year uh
now that now that jimmy cobb has fully
gone to the dark side and has started
using the new rubberized bench shirts
feel like the sky's the limit who knows
what he's gonna push the record to
that's awesome well you can find both of
those videos in the show notes for
today's episode um now moving on
i have a coach's corner segment i'm
going to try to keep this brief because
i know you've got a really nice research
roundup or research review coming up
but what i wanted to do was a really
applied segment that talks a little bit
about how to actually troubleshoot
metabolic adaptation or i should say
apparent metabolic adaptation so to set
this up i want to start with a problem
statement okay so you or maybe your
client
are struggling with weight loss and for
this segment i'm just going to present
it from a coach's perspective so let's
say a client comes to you or like a
brand new client who wants to work with
you and says
i'd like some help with weight loss but
you really have your work cut out for
you because i am stalled and something's
just not right here
so you're talking to this individual and
they feel like they're doing all the
right things to promote an energy
deficit but their weight just is not
budging right so a very common
assumption is to go straight to
metabolic adaptation
um and to kind of assume well the
problem here is low resting metabolic
rate or maybe low total daily energy
expenditure but
you really have to dig deeper i mean
maybe it is low but how low is it and
you know how low could it possibly get
and how might we overcome this situation
whether it actually truly is due to low
energy expenditure or
maybe it's actually due to something
else entirely so you really have to dig
in and start exploring this um
so one of the first questions that comes
up is oh should i just have this person
get their resting metabolic rate tested
i've had a number of people reach out to
me on the internet and say hey i was
thinking about getting my resting
metabolic rate tested
should i do that um
and i
basically always say no
you know it's
knowing your resting metabolic rate in
the absence of knowing your total daily
energy expenditure for weight loss
purposes is not particularly useful
um and it's also really hard to get a
good measurement outside of a research
setting um you know unless you're going
in
and working with people who have been
really well trained and using really
nice
indirect calorimetry equipment a lot of
the commercial grade stuff just isn't
that good and
we're talking about
uh
lacking precision and having error to
the extent that it's like you might as
well just use a formula you know in many
cases so i don't recommend that
another question is well maybe i should
just calculate an estimated total daily
energy expenditure uh compare that with
their daily calorie target and maybe
that alone can tell me how severe this
metabolic adaptation truly is
that is still not a perfect approach
the reason being you know you can try to
calculate estimated energy expenditure
based on age body composition
physical activity correction factors
things like that
and it can get you into a general
ballpark number
but if a person is it kind of deviates
from that estimate
that's not necessarily an indicator that
something is going wrong or that they're
experiencing metabolic adaptation
as we've talked about previously there's
a lot of variation from person to person
uh you know you might
be able to calculate someone's predicted
total daily energy expenditure but
that's just going to get you within the
ballpark and there are going to be
people who without any metabolic
adaptation whatsoever are far above and
far a lot far below that predicted value
so what we need to do here is not just
crunch numbers in a formula not just
go get measured at some kind of like
commercial
gym that offers metabolic rate
assessments what we need to do here is
what i call an energy audit and so for
this segment i want to walk through how
i go about doing that because i think
it'll be helpful for people who find
themselves in this situation either with
their own dieting or working with a
potential client so this segment is
going to be very practical it's going to
acknowledge some topics we've talked
about previously so obviously it's going
to talk about metabolic adaptation it's
going to talk about
compensating for the calories we burn
during exercise we've gone into the
details about the research behind these
topics but we haven't really tied it
together into a very applied segment
like this so
the general vibe first when you're going
to conduct an energy audit and what
we're trying to do here is figure out
what what truly are the numbers here the
calories in and the calories out we need
to get into the details to figure out is
there really an unusual discrepancy here
is total daily energy expenditure really
way out of the normal range
the general vibe when you're conducting
an energy audit it's going to be a
conversation it's back and forth a lot
of questions a lot of
follow-up questions to kind of dig into
the details the most important thing is
ask the questions but actually listen
you know listening is critically
important with this because when you're
trying to conduct this kind of energy
audit working with a client the only
true source of information is going to
be their experience their perspective
and what they're able to relay so you
have to ask questions and you have to
truly listen deeply and intently you
also need to make sure that you're being
empathetic and compassionate in the
process so you're aiming to be helpful
here now it's very easy to go on this
energy audit
and
you hear their initial
problem
and
you might be skeptical at first and say
no no no you're making a mistake with
your tracking right so you can start
this process from a a place of
skepticism and it almost seems like
you're trying to assign assign some
blame you know it's like you're trying
to figure out where they messed up uh
and of course we're going to ask a lot
of questions uh that do probe a little
bit in terms of accuracy and how well
they're tracking but it's really
important to remind yourself before you
have this conversation
i'm here to be helpful not to assign
blame okay so uh sometimes people go
into this and they they try to use a
tough love approach
and i generally think that's a bad idea
you know i think tough love is a
misunderstood concept in coaching in
general i think
uh in many instances in most instances
there's a much better way to communicate
rather than what most people consider
like yeah i just do tough love and you
know i'm really hard on my clients but
they're better for it you know so like
you could tell someone like hey you know
this is what it takes to achieve your
goal you can either handle it or you
can't that's up to you you know you can
kind of take that approach that leans on
that tough love and say i'm dropping
this truth on you and you're not gonna
like it but like you could also
do that differently you could say like
listen your goal it's really ambitious
and that's fantastic like having
ambitious goals is exciting but
you know we have to operate within the
natural constraints of physiology so i
don't think that your goal physique can
actually be obtained without the
following trade-offs and downsides and
then you lay those out and you say let's
go through a cost-benefit analysis and
determine
what body composition level is going to
be compatible with your physique-related
ambitions while also being compatible
with the way you want to
the way you want to live your life and
the way that you want to feel throughout
the day
so in both cases you have delivered
a truthful statement that's a little bit
inconvenient but one of them is very
helpful and understanding and the other
is not so my concern with people who are
a coach and they're really proud of
their tough love approach
is that i just think it's usually not
the best approach
and
you know there are ways to deliver
truthful statements um
that you know have less than than
or or deliver feedback that's not
favorable you know there might be areas
where you have to say hey we really need
to improve on this you can deliver those
truths without being abrasive
and if you look into some of the
research on self-determination theory
that research would indicate that
the abrasive approach
probably is not doing a lot to support
that athlete's success in the long term
so
i i do kind i find it a little bit
amusing that there are a lot of people
who are like
you know they're evidence-based coaches
and they're proud of it and they tell
you all the time i'm evidence-based and
they mock people for being out of step
with the nutrition literature or the
exercise literature
but their actual job is coaching and
they are fully out of step with the
coaching literature you know like like
they are missing an entire field of
science that would make them better at
it well there
there is a more cynical interpretation
which is so when you say you think tough
love isn't a good approach the question
you then need to ask yourself is a good
approach for who
um
you know and is is that going to be the
optimal approach to
um
improve the results for that particular
client versus is that the optimal
approach to
improve the profitability of your
coaching program
and i think that for
uh some percentage of coaches
i
i don't think people are actually like
sitting down and thinking through this
but i think that
you maybe notice trends over time where
uh clients who respond well to that
tough love approach where essentially
what you're saying is a coach is like
hey here's the decision you need to make
uh and that's that's 100 on you and if
you make this decision where you are
going to
do all of the things you need to do to
reach your goals without me reminding
you or without us having ongoing
conversations about this stuff
uh you know you'll probably get good
results and you're going to be a very
low effort client for me uh versus you
know a more collaborative approach where
there's more conversations that take
place
um you know more little trade-offs you
talk about
on a more frequent basis
that may
improve the odds on a per client basis
of client success but it's also
increasing the weekly workload per
client and so i think i think some
percentage of coaches
maybe subconsciously realize that that
tough love approach uh increases the
size of the roster that they can
maintain
by by weeding out
people who are like truly driven and
want to have success but may take a
little bit more effort for the coach to
help them get there
so yeah i mean
i
agree i agree with your statement that
tough love may not be the best approach
if
maximizing per client odds of success
is the end point you care about the most
yeah but i don't necessarily
know that that is a true assumption for
everyone all the time well that's
because you didn't take the road to
enlightenment you know you have all that
cynicism built up and yeah yeah you're
definitely correct uh unfortunately um
but
one day i will do a segment on
self-determination theory and get more
into the details but when you look into
that research this whole tough love
approach
usually
you'll see things dichotomized sometimes
as
autonomy-supporting behaviors of a coach
versus controlling behaviors of a coach
autonomy supporting behaviors are
fantastic they empower the client and
and really
favorably impact a number of positive
psychological outcomes controlling
behaviors
really chip away at the root of
self-determination theory and leave
clients in a position where their
psychological needs are not being met
and their long-term success is far less
likely
so tough love kind of checks quite a few
of the boxes for these controlling
behaviors that based on literally
like all of the psychology research and
the coaching research uh
can lead to some pretty unfavorable
long-term outcomes and just really
detract from the well-being and the
enjoyment of the client so
uh yeah i think some people um
uh are probably doing this because like
you said it's way easier to just say
well i gave you the plan you either do
it or you don't like that that's a lot
easier than like truly troubleshooting
something but i also think some some
people kind of pick up from other
coaches that that's a successful way to
do things and and you know kind of get
led astray or they're or they're just
modeling behave like reproducing
behaviors that have been modeled for
them in other coaching contexts like
yeah maybe you become a trainer because
you had another trainer who took the
tough love approach with you or you just
played sports growing up and that's the
approach that like your your basketball
coach or football coach took with you
yeah for sure um but anyway i'm i'm way
into this segment and i haven't
mentioned one thing about what i was
trying to get at so i'm gonna move along
here like i said we'll we'll definitely
have more of a like coaching psychology
discussion about self-determination
theory at some point um but for now
we're going to do this this uh energy
audit right we need to figure out more
about the energy coming in and the
energy expenditure on a daily basis so
there are a number of areas to explore
here so first of all their strength
training uh habits
um you know
total energy expenditure during
resistance exercise you had a great
research brief on this in the mass
research review it's about six calories
per minute
you can do a little bit of calculation
that that's their basal energy
expenditure plus exercise that's all
lumped together the total energy
expenditure is generally about six
calories per minute of course there are
variables you can tweak to change that
but but if you're trying to just kind of
sketch out how many calories we're
burning in the gym that's where you can
start
you can crunch some numbers and kind of
if you want to calculate the additive
effect rather than the total effect you
can do that but the first thing you want
to do is get an idea of
how often are we lifting what do these
workouts look like
and you know
how much energy are we really burning in
the gym on a daily or a weekly basis and
of course we should also expect on
average that about 30 percent of those
calories are going to be compensated for
so when you're trying to figure out how
these exercise calories are contributing
to total daily energy expenditure
uh it might be that you know whatever
number you calculate for extra you know
lifting related exercise calories per
week
you might need to multiply that by like
0.5 or 0.7 to get a really good estimate
of how much that's actually impacting
total daily energy expenditure because
of compensation which we've discussed
many times on the show before
now you want to also look at their
cardio program and obviously you want to
look at frequency intensity duration
volume consistency of how frequently
they're doing these things but one thing
that gets overlooked a lot in these
energy audits aside from the obvious
stuff is modality right so when they're
doing cardio is it cardio that's using
several large muscle groups you know
cycling and running are not exactly the
same in in terms of total energy
expenditure when you're running and you
have you know more musculature involved
in general
the average person can put a lot more
energy into running than they can
cycling
among workouts that they perceive to be
equivalent in terms of difficulty
um
another thing to keep in mind is any
modality where there's the capacity to
to kind of quote unquote cheat in a way
that lowers energy costs so
for example when you become more skilled
at an exercise modality
you're uh you're not cheating but your
expenditure will go down over time and
like the best uh example i can think of
for that when i started swimming for
cardio and i literally couldn't swim i
burnt so many calories because all of my
motion was wasted right but if you go
from being a terrible swimmer to a great
swimmer and you're doing the same
distance in your workouts your energy
expenditure is going way down
so uh
economy is linked to skill acquisition
and the more skill you build with a
modality you could be
making your exercise more efficient
which is great for performance but not
great for burning energy and burning
calories so
another thing is you know little
opportunities to do something that
that's more in line with that idea of
cheating so like when i'm doing laps in
the pool how much am i kicking off the
wall versus truly you know
going through the swimming motion to
propel myself
the biggest one in my opinion is
handrails
people on the on the stair master
holding on to the handrails people doing
incline
treadmill walking holding on to the
handrails has a big impact on reducing
energy expenditure um you know growing
up
growing up
makes it sound like i was like 10. back
in my day when i was an undergrad
student
they train you in exercise science as if
you're basically going to become like a
cardiac rehab
specialist
uh that's how a lot of the coursework is
oriented at least in in in my uh
experience i know so many things about
reading in ekg that i'm never going to
use exactly but but they used to always
warn us if you're doing a stress test
for diagnostic purposes and you're going
to be reading that ekg at a very high
intensity
if you're letting the participant hold
the handles of the treadmill you could
completely botch the test because they
might not be able to get up to a
sufficient intensity to see some of
those key indicators in the ekg like
they might not physically be able to get
their heart to that workload level where
you can see some of those key indicators
you're looking for so i mean i was on
the the stair master the other day i was
going to go for a run and it was rainy
and i i don't use the handrails i did
like 15 minutes and felt like i was
dying like the stairmaster should be
hard as hell
uh and if you're if you're holding onto
the handrails you can really go for like
i mean i was looking next to me and
everyone was going for like 40 minutes i
did 15. i was like you guys are crazy
i'm out but holding the handrails was
like the big distinction there yeah uh
so you got to think about exercise
modality
on top of those other things and again
if i told you my best handrail
treadmill story no
so uh back in the day god how long ago
was this i think i was still in high
school um
anyway training at this gym and there
were you know quite a few other lifters
and uh there was this guy who i think he
was just doing cardio after his workout
to try to lose weight to drop a weight
class or something like that um
but anyway he was uh like he was on a
treadmill and just doing kind of like
leisurely incline walking watching
watching the tv that's in front of him
and i [ __ ] you not like he was holding
on to the handles of of the treadmill
strapped in like like he had he had
lifting straps on the handle and i was
like dude what what are you doing it's
like i just deadlifted like my grips
worn out
and i was just thinking like dude if if
you
if your grip might become a limiting
factor for your ability to walk on a
treadmill
your whole dog too damn tight like that
that should never be the limiter of your
ability to walk on a treadmill
um yeah so yeah that's that's an extreme
example but
yeah
no but uh that that does remind me one
last thing so
when you're looking through cardio again
you can do some quick calculations but
you have to factor energy compensation
again um but one thing i wanted to
mention i'm not saying that you should
all go and get on a stair master and not
use the handles you should only do
cardio modalities that you feel
comfortable doing safely right and so
like
i'm on the stairmaster not using the
handles but my hands are literally
hovering over them so that if i lose
balance i can grab them if you don't
trust your balance well enough to do a
stairmaster or an inclined treadmill
walking workout without using the
handrails that's okay
um but but you you need to make sure you
find a modality that is that you feel
comfortable doing safely you know so if
balance is an issue maybe those aren't
the modalities for you or maybe you
still hold the handrails but you at
least have the knowledge i am pretty
significantly reducing my energy
expenditure here
um now moving on you want to go with
this client you want to talk through
their non-exercise activity so you want
to ask some questions you know what kind
of job do you have if it's an office job
that's going to be brutal for their
total daily energy expenditure like
sedentary jobs can really put a cap on
your energy expenditure unless you're
very intentionally getting more activity
outside of work you want to talk to them
about their home life um obviously like
you want to talk about their home life
as it pertains to energy expenditure so
for example
a lot of people gain weight after
college when they move from a campus
setting to a tradition a more
traditional home setting and they're not
walking to every single activity that
they do
you might
move from an urban setting where you
walk to the grocery store and you walk
to the park and things like that and
then move to a rural setting where
literally nothing is within a walkable
distance and so all of a sudden you're
in the car more so you want to talk
about those aspects of home life and
just talk about their leisure time you
know like i have noticed that as i get
older uh now in my fourth decade of life
i don't do the same leisure time
activities i used to do that kept my
energy expenditure up
and again this non-exercise activity is
still physical activity so we do have to
factor in energy compensation
moving on to diet you want to get an
idea of this individual's daily calorie
target that they're shooting for
one thing you have to ask yourself is is
it actually lower
than kind of the normal anticipated
range sometimes it isn't this is
something we've talked about on the show
sometimes people will come to you and
say
my calorie intake is way too low it's
it's tremendously inappropriate for
someone my size and then you look at
their their body size and activity level
you say
nah like that's that's pretty normal um
but but there are a lot of people on
social media with really strong
marketing who are like
yeah all my clients are like five
percent body fat and they eat 4 000
calories a day and if you're not able to
do that there's something wrong with you
also
by my book and my coaching you know like
so that that's something that that uh
the evidence-based fitness world has to
really
push against uh some people just have um
people have been given expectations for
calorie intake that maybe aren't
realistic
you want to get an idea after you talk
about daily calorie targets get an idea
of consistency and adherence so any
untracked meals untracked days
binge eating episodes
one common thing is just kind of taking
bites and taking a taste of food from
your kids or your partner that you live
with
that's very common untracked vegetables
untracked sauces condiments oils cooking
sprays when those things are untracked
but consumed regularly that can start to
drive your calorie intake up even though
you think you're eating far less
and one thing that some people will do
is they'll say man i switched to all
these healthy foods and my body weight
is still really stuck
but sometimes you'll notice when people
talk about switching you know what they
consider an unhealthy food to a healthy
food they haven't really moved the
needle in terms of actual calorie intake
you know someone might say yeah instead
of sugar i use a lot more honey but it's
you know it's still the same amount of
total total caloric intake so you want
to go through that and you also want to
go through their diet history so
what's really fascinating is when you
can talk through
someone's history and figure out have
there ever been times where you had
successful attempts with weight loss and
you start to understand the
circumstances of that successful attempt
in the past the characteristics uh and
you can start to piece together what's
missing now right so oh can i just add
one more thing to your prior list sure
yeah uh
eating out frequently at restaurants
which like absolutely nothing wrong with
that but
one it's very easy to just forget about
a lot of the things you eat at a
restaurant like hey i went to a mexican
restaurant i got a burrito and a
margarita okay like i remember that well
did they put chips and salsa on the
table oh yeah yeah i also ate like four
baskets of chips you know um
or uh you know
you remember the big thing you got and
there was an appetizer for the table and
like you said on track bites like uh
maybe i had like one or two little bites
of the appetizer and uh unless i i was
gonna say unless the restaurant posts
its its calorie information online even
if it does that's that's a crap shoot um
i don't think that
uh that's actually strictly enforced
like i don't think restaurants are
actually out here getting in trouble if
they're
if the calories of the foods they have
posted are
lower than what's in the actual dish
but yeah you know nothing wrong with
eating out at restaurants but
i wouldn't count that the same as like
untracked meals as you mentioned but
if you are eating out at restaurants
pretty frequently at minimum there's a
pretty big question mark um
because yeah you you don't actually know
how much total food it is you don't know
how much fat was added in the
preparation there are probably
a few little things that you eat
throughout a meal that you just don't
think about after the meal is over uh so
yeah right eating out frequently at
restaurants is
is it at least another thing to take
inventory of yeah that's a very a very
good addition um but yeah the the next
one i was talking about diet history it
can be really informative if you compare
and contrast like what is different
about this current unsuccessful weight
loss attempt when we compare it to past
very successful weight loss attempts and
sometimes you'll see
someone switched to a sedentary job from
a more active job they moved to a less
walkable area
you know they got married and had kids
and they're not sleeping as well and
they're kind of taking bites of food
from their family
you know they stop pursuing physically
active leisure time activities because
they're busier with their family
responsibilities there's a long list of
things that can change that make a
really big difference
and then of course when talking about
diet history you want to get an idea of
whether or not this per like some people
have been really aggressively
restricting for a very very long time
and sometimes those are cases where you
do see some fairly substantial genuine
metabolic adaptation happening and along
those lines the final thing you want to
talk through with your energy audit is
symptoms of low energy availability so
when someone has very low energy
availability and they're they're really
likely to have metabolic adaptation
there's usually some signs of that you
know hunger uh being lethargic having a
kind of an increase in injury rate
recently with their training
obviously disruption of menstrual cycle
low libido
uh impaired sleep quality uh obviously
if they have hormone information if you
start to see that
you know thyroid hormones or sex
hormones or getting out of whack those
can be indicators that we're seeing uh
the physiological signs of really ex you
know fairly substantial energy
restrictions so
that was a long list that's a lot of
stuff to talk through this usually takes
a full hour without without question and
sometimes even longer
but the reason that we ask so many
detailed questions is because we are
searching for maybe
two to three hundred calories per day
worth of of metabolic adaptation if it
exists but in order to find that we have
to rule out all other potential sources
of inaccurate tracking or just improper
estimation of energy in or energy out
so
when i run into a situation where we do
this energy audit and we see that
yeah we're looking at a discrepancy of
like 600 calories that we can't find
that usually
is is a suggestion to me that we're
talking about some missing calories that
are not attributable to metabolic
adaptation like
true metabolic adaptation in most cases
you're going to see that we're talking
about a magnitude of up to 200 maybe 300
calories per day
kind of at the higher end of what you
regularly see
so that's actually good news like if you
can find some of these calories and you
don't have to
say that all of it is true physiological
adaptation that's terrific because it's
way easier to resolve what is basically
an accounting issue versus resolving
physiology issues like if you can say oh
actually yeah i've been eating 400 more
calories than i thought
that that's an easy solution that we can
then troubleshoot so
as you're going through this you've
collected this information you want to
go through some different scenarios that
will lead you to tentative conclusions
as you're reviewing so like when i see
these scenarios here's the first place
my brain goes and then of course it's a
conversation and you probe deeper but if
i see someone with this stalled weight
loss and they've got some untracked
meals or days or frequent binges or as
you added very regular restaurant eating
my concern is that we probably just
aren't getting a good estimate of our
calorie intake you know
the fact that we have these untracked
days or meals we've got these binging
episodes we've got a lot of uh
restaurant prepared meals to that makes
me think we might have an issue with
accuracy of nutrition tracking now if i
see someone with stalled weight loss and
there are just absolutely no symptoms of
low energy availability i'm thinking
along the same lines we might have an
issue with dietary adherence or we might
just have an issue with the accuracy of
dietary tracking because
we're thinking we're consuming this
really low calorie intake but we're not
showing any of the signs of like
substantial energy restriction
which again is good we can troubleshoot
and get to the bottom of that if i see
someone who has stalled weight loss with
a very cardio heavy approach so they're
leaning very much on cardio for weight
loss the biggest issue there could be
modality selection like we talked about
it could be significant energy
compensation which is observed from time
to time uh it's also possible that the
individual has a really major hunger
response to high amounts of cardio which
you do see a lot of variability from
person to person there
on the flip side if i see this stalled
weight loss with a very low cardio or no
cardio approach my first thought is we
probably have very low daily energy
expenditure we might want to work in
either structured cardio or
other less structured physical activity
to try to just move the needle for total
daily energy expenditure uh and kind of
a fringe benefit of doing that is
sometimes people actually
kind of paradoxically have increased
hunger due to low physical activity so
so you can sometimes add a little bit of
cardio and help people regulate their
appetite and hunger a little bit better
but like i said some people they go too
high with the cardio and then the hunger
gets gets really excessive so you want
to try to thread the needle there and
listen to the individual's experience
sometimes you'll see stalled weight loss
that very clearly coincides with a major
life change new job new house new baby
things like that issues there could
relate to just low physical activity low
energy expenditure
also anything that disrupts your sleep
to a significant degree can really alter
your hunger and reward responses so
you'll seek out more
hedonic eating opportunities a lot of
times calorie increase will or calorie
intake will increase in a way that is
not truly intentional or volitional so
that's something to keep an eye out for
and then of course if i see someone with
stalled weight loss who has very clear
signs of low energy availability that
usually is an indicator we're probably
talking about at least some degree of of
legit metabolic adaptation here so
that's kind of the troubleshooting
process and you start kind of putting
putting things together and getting an
idea of where do we have to dig deeper
to figure out how to account for these
different calories and then you know
what's the next move we basically have
three different options here
um we can try to
re-establish adherence and consistency
and accuracy with tracking
and basically do a maintenance phase and
what we're trying to do there is
re-establish that consistency
improve any inaccuracies in our tracking
and get a really great idea of
what is the calorie intake where i
really effectively maintain my body
weight and it's there's twofold benefits
it's a little bit of a psychological
break from intense dieting and it also
gives us a very valuable number if you
know your total daily energy expenditure
you are empowered to move forward with
greater confidence when you're setting a
weight loss goal you know the numbers
that you're working with at that point
option two is you can still address
whatever issue seems to be present but
try to keep pushing forward
with that weight loss attempt that's
currently in process so
rather than kind of
pressing pause and maintaining and
identifying total daily energy
expenditure you go through and you say
okay our best guess is that we've been
uh you
know we've got an estimation error of
approximately this many calories so
let's drop our calorie target to this
number and keep pushing forward so so
there is the opportunity to do that um
and so you want to just go and address
like maybe you switch your cardio
modality maybe you change your cardio
volume you work on a different step
count goal there's a lot of different
ways to address the issues that were
identified in the audit and keep pushing
forward without a maintenance phase
and then option three you could uh you
know maybe try something like reverse
dieting if it looks like you could do a
diet break or reverse dieting if it
looks like there's some really
substantial metabolic adaptation and the
prospect of pushing forward seems to be
unsustainable and i don't want to get
into the diet break and reverse dieting
stuff because we've already covered that
in a lot of depth on the show previously
but um
in any case you know what we're trying
to do here is
ask questions listen identify areas
where we might have inaccuracies in
terms of energy intake and energy
consumption and then just recalibrating
the process to figure out how we push
forward
and unfortunately one situation you
might run into
is as i alluded to in my example about
tough love and the alternate way you can
frame that news sometimes you do run
into a situation where
a person's ideal physique
is not compatible with what they
consider to be a sustainable lifestyle
and in that situation it's not an easy
solution but i think sometimes you have
to just sit down and talk through kind
of a cost-benefit analysis of what if we
aim for this level of leanness versus
that level you know how do we find a way
to achieve your goal while also having a
lifestyle that you feel comfortable with
and you know
sometimes that involves recalibrating
the goal sometimes it involves framing
the goal as more transient in nature so
someone might say i can't sustain this
lifestyle that is required to get to six
percent body fat you say okay
let's talk about when we want to be six
percent body fat and for how long and
kind of work back from there with more
of a calendar approach of when we do the
less sustainable techniques and when we
do the more sustainable techniques and
how we manage body composition it's
almost like a periodization for your
leanness over the course of a one year
schedule so there's a lot of options for
how you navigate that conversation but
sometimes you will find that we need to
recalibrate expectations for you know
what is uh
my ideal physique that is also
compatible with the way i want to live
and the way i want to feel each day so
there's a lot that goes into that
process of the energy audit and then the
ultimate conclusions of where you go
from there but
i get a lot of questions of you know
someone presents with suspected
metabolic adaptation that appears to be
extreme in magnitude what do you do
i do that you know we go through that
process start to finish and uh
yeah
that's all i got
we are we're running very very long yeah
that's obvious uh do you want to do your
research roundup or do you want to save
that for a later time i'm comfortable
with either because i know that i just
stole the entire show well
i wouldn't phrase it like that you uh
took up a lot of time on the show
whether or not you stole the show
that might be a touch more
self-congratulatory than
i'm comfortable with we'll see in the in
the comments how people feel
uh no that that's totally fine my my
feats of strength also ran long um
yeah we we can we can push my segment
back yeah we'll definitely we'll start
out with that one next time around and
make sure that we uh we'll give you a
chance to steal the show and see if yeah
i mean i
it's it's no big deal i don't care uh i
took time out of my valuable vacation to
prepare this segment um
yeah who who cares my time my time
doesn't matter
uh i'm just the guest here who who gives
a [ __ ] that's a good point anything i do
or anything i care about yeah i don't
remember if i apologize but if i do
if i did i want to retract that now that
you put it that way
um now to play us out
uh greg are you familiar with football
american football i've heard of it so
there's the national football league um
and they have a combine every year where
all of the
promising
prospects for the upcoming nfl draft uh
run through a battery of
fitness tests uh and a variety of other
tests as well basically the nfl teams
want to figure out everything they can
figure out about
uh the athletes who are going to be
entering the upcoming draft um and there
were some numbers that just cannot be
ignored and we we simply must
acknowledge them so all of this
information is coming from cbssports.com
and i focused on the 40-yard dash um
so 40 yards is
36.6 meters roughly and it is kind of
the single speed metric that
american football organizations are
really enamored with um the football
field is a hundred yards but you know
the 40 yard dash is kind of the the
prime number especially for the skill
positions receivers running backs
defensive backs but they have everybody
run it and it gets a lot of attention so
the first thing that caught my eye was
a pair of wide receivers from ohio state
garrett wilson and chris o'lave both ran
under a 4.4 second
40-yard dash so garrett wilson came in
at 4.38 seconds olave at 4.39
that was his official time his
unofficial time was like 4.26
and i saw that on twitter and i was like
what
uh but they did correct it after the
fact um but anyway i saw those two
numbers and it made my
it made me sad i was like we
ohio state should have won at least 16
games last year and i know you can only
win 15 but that honestly kind of broke
my heart well and then when both of them
don't play in the bowl game and you just
see how good jackson smith and jigba is
when he has the chance to be the number
one target
yeah
i mean ohio state had a very good season
by most program standards uh but yeah
you you see that and you're like ah
should have been so much more yeah uh
and dude marvin harrison jr as well uh
another upcoming receiver so the
future's bright but man i saw that and i
was like we
you just think we we could have done
more with it uh some really crazy speed
uh taekwon thornton and kaylon barnes
um
they are both out of baylor
one is a wide receiver the other a
cornerback a defensive back they both
ran under a 4-3 so 4.28 and 4.29 seconds
that is absolutely crazy when you start
talking about getting below 4.3 seconds
you're talking about the all-time elite
combine performances for the 40 yard
dash so that is
unbelievable without any qualification
whatsoever
uh now getting into the really
interesting stuff that i find even more
impressive um because we'll throw in
some qualifiers here that
are almost hard to believe so there were
eight athletes categorized as edge
rushers
who ran a 4.58 or below
uh and so these are these are like
defensive ends so like for example amari
barno uh from virginia tech ran a 4.36
he's listed at
245 pounds
that is
that's outrageous yeah so he's he's
almost 250 which is like 113 kilograms
running a 4.36 just simply doesn't make
sense i understand that physics exists
but not in a world where that happens
it it it almost makes you feel for
quarterbacks and like it makes sense why
there are so many more mobile
quarterbacks now you can't you can't
just shift around in the pocket a little
bit and get out of the way of that
yeah you don't see a lot of drew
bledsoes anymore yeah you got to be a
little quicker than that these days
um
now here here's a crazy stat
uh 12 linemen so i i don't think they
included edge rushers as linemen here so
we're talking interior linemen and
offensive linemen 12 of them broke the
five-second barrier uh which you think
you know five seconds after the numbers
we've discussed might not sound that
impressive but we're talking about
people who weigh a lot and rarely have
to cover 40 yards in a play so it's it's
not an area where they specialize
except for the couple months leading up
to the draft um but here are two numbers
that are just insane devonta wyatt from
georgia ran 4.77
at a body weight of 315 pounds or 143
kilograms
itch the amount of force that that
person is putting through the ground
with each stride is is absolutely
it's hard to wrap your head around it's
preposterous it is
and you might be thinking that's the
craziest thing that i'm gonna tell you
but it's actually not
um
jordan davis his teammate so bear in
mind if you're on the other team both of
these men are running at you at the same
time there's two of them yes yeah so his
teammate jordan davis ran a
4.78 40-yard dash
at a weight of
341 pounds or 155 kilograms
there's no there's no reason that
someone that large should be able to
move that fast yeah that's completely
unconscionable so realistic so like if
you're not a particularly mobile
quarterback
you might be running in the four sevens
you know like that that's maybe about
where you're at so if you're a
quarterback on the other team uh you
have
almost 700 pounds
worth of these two gentlemen chasing you
with that type of speed that is not a
place that i'd like to be and that might
have something to do with why georgia
won the championship last year yeah i'm
pretty sure both of those guys have
faster 40 times than patrick mahomes who
you know he's no lamar jackson but he's
a he's a perfectly adequate scrambler
when he needs to get out of the pocket
and and get a first down but yeah both
both of these guys are faster than him
yeah yeah so it's incredible i i don't
like watch the combine every year but i
do go into the data afterwards and just
say
okay surprise me again you know like
let's see what we've got and
this year was no exception people really
put on quite a performance so
congratulations to all those athletes
for a terrific combine performance and i
hope that they have good fortune when it
comes to the draft coming up
all right so that does it for this
episode
as always thank you so much for joining
us and we hope that you'll join us next
week where greg is going to have the
four will be yours i i can't wait to see
what you have in store for us so
thanks as always and we will see you in
one week
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top if you want
to join in on the stronger by science
podcast conversation be sure to check
out our facebook group and our subreddit
the links for both are provided in the
description of today's episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you